we are back
with the man the myth and the legend
plan b
plan b can you hear me
i can anthony john joe hi how are you
doing we're doing fantastic how are you
yeah very good very good i i bet you are
all right first i want to start with uh
stock to flow model uh you're the
creator of this and most people point to
it as uh kind of the single guiding
light to them in terms of uh the
relationship of bitcoin's price to these
halving cycles so talk us through a
little bit about what the stock to flow
model is and then what it's showing us
so far
yeah so the stock to flow ratio is a
ratio from the commodities market
actually that that tells you something
about an assets scarcity
um
it divides the stock the the reserves of
a certain assets uh by the flow the
newly issued
bitcoins or or gold newly mined gold and
if you divide the stock by the flow you
get the stock to flow ratio so that
ratio was known for ages in the
commodities market what i did was
connect that with the market value of uh
well bitcoin in the beginning but later
also the other assets
uh like silver and diamonds and gold and
real estate and what you find that there
is a perfect linear relationship in the
logarithmic space so that was quite
shocking and and with that you can uh
you can actually predict the price of
bitcoin very roughly i should say but
you can do it
and uh because we know the stock to flow
ratio of uh of bitcoin it's it's
pre-programmed and that's yeah that's a
very nice thing
and it it's of course very bullish
at the moment it predicts um
somewhere around 100 000
bitcoin for the current halving cycle
which is 2020 2024
so we're actually heading towards that
yeah it's uh it's that so when you think
of the stock to flow ratio one of the
things that i'm fascinated by is it
comes from the commodities market but
it's actually potentially more accurate
when it comes to bitcoin because we know
with certainty and can prove the supply
of both the outstanding supply and the
daily incoming supply describe a little
bit about why that certainty and that
that verifiability is so important to
the accuracy of a model like this
yeah so for example with gold we don't
know how much gold is mined every year
it's it's uh we can make a forecast
but we don't know it um precisely and a
lot of factors impact that that uh
supply that that mind supply of of uh
gold and one of the factors impacting
that is is price right if the price of
gold is high then the miners will will
increase their production and if the
price of gold is low they will decrease
the production and the mining of gold
with bitcoin
um
yeah well the whole production the whole
flow is pre-programmed every 10 minutes
on average right every 10 minutes
there's a block and in that block is a
block subsidy
um with the new bitcoins for the miner
that found the hash of that block so uh
we know sort of that every 10 minutes
and and for the whole year
uh how how much bitcoins will be mined
of course we don't know it exactly
because there is some um
variability in the in the 10 minute
interval sometimes it it lasts an hour
sometimes you have like three blocks in
in 10 minutes but on average we know and
especially long term we know what the
stock to flow ratio will be and thus
what the price will be roughly
so when you think about these having
cycles obviously there's a supply shock
um but how do you think about
kind of the cyclical nature of this
right is there a point where you expect
the model or ratio to be invalidated uh
either through external forces um or
people start to uh kind of price it in
and front run it like how do you think
about uh the fact that we do know the
supply and that helps for the accuracy
of uh stock to flow but at some point
does that become a
negative yeah there's several aspects to
that um
of course from efficient market
hypothesis you would expect that this
knowledge uh and the model would be
priced in so i actually and most people
with me expected the halving
uh the may 2020 halving would be priced
in already so we did we would not see
the actual price rise that we're seeing
now
that is
very much in line with the stock to flow
model because all the information is out
there the stock information the flow the
stock flow ratio and the model so it
shouldn't follow the model as closely as
it does today
on the other hand there's there's a lot
of people not believing the model and
the model of course hasn't proven itself
so
maybe that that sort of
puts the efficient market hypothesis
argument aside but on the other hand um
i think that
the
stock to flow
model
will break uh in the future because um
one of the nice things about the stock
to flow uh model and especially the
stock flow cross asset model instructor
x model which also inc incorporates data
from the gold market diamond market real
estate market and silver market so other
uh stores of value if you will
if we
um
look at that stock to flow x model
we can interpolate the data
uh because gold has a higher stock to
flow ratio than bitcoin and real estate
has a higher stock to flow ratio gold is
60 around 60 and real estate is around
hundreds uh where bitcoin is
50 55 right now
um so we know we can within the data set
we have available with with gold and and
and real estate in there with market
values of of
10 trillion
for the gold market and 100 trillion for
a real estate market we can we can
interpolate within the data set
and and of course that ends because if
bitcoin
will have its next halving in 2024
the bitcoin stock to throw ratio will
jump to 100 which is very cl yeah which
is approximately the same as
real estate
um
but
after next halfing or we jump to 200
stock flow ratio for bitcoin we're out
of the model data
bounds if you will and then we have to
extrapolate which which is what
basically all the other models are doing
they're extrapolating into the future
which is very dangerous and one of the
big assets big advantages of the stock
to flow model the stock x model in
particular is that this interpolation
can be done so
to be in short i think
the stock to flow model
uh will end uh to be valid somewhere
after next halving when the structure
flow is above 100 because we cannot
interpolate anymore and of course that
that means probably that the dollar
the denominator in that model
will
end
to play a big role or or or something
and of course it doesn't say that
bitcoin will die or something it's it's
or you know it's just the model will not
be very accurate after that for sure and
one of the things that i appreciate
about you is not only can you look at
something like the stock to flow model
and talk about um kind of the cyclical
natures of the havings but also you've
got a very good understanding of market
structures
and various things that happen on the
exchanges you had a tweet recently
talking about these cell walls as kind
of pure scare tactics and we've pulled
up the tweet here describe a little bit
more about what goes on in these order
books with these cell walls and how
folks are using them as a scare tactic
yeah what most people maybe don't know
is my background is in institutional
investment and i've been in the
institutional investor roles
my entire life so i um started at a
daily a dealing room in ethics trading
then went to banking balance sheets and
and insurance balance sheets and lately
my latest job was
managing a pension balance sheet with
the team uh and their balance sheet was
100 billion uh us dollars approximately
so
i yeah i spent my life chasing those
those charts that you have in front
there and then chasing those cell walls
and by walls
and i yeah what i noticed was that most
people are sort of scared by those big
walls those big big uh cell walls in
this case
in that chart
um
and and of course
most of the time not all the time most
of the time these sell walls are just
there to scare people in uh
not buying or or even selling
and um
because they signal um well don't come
here or this at price level where the
cell wall is because we will
uh we will sell and we will keep the
price under this level but in fact what
you see in real life nine and ten times
you see that as as the price approaches
the cell wall
uh the cell will gets gets gets
cancelled and moved
further away so
in this case the price uh the cell will
be moved at a higher price
so it's it's just scare tactics and
i thought it was a good thing for uh
to to to put that in the tweet for other
people to know for sure no i i think
that people really appreciate that one
uh when you start to think about whether
it's the cell walls on the order books
whether it's the stock to flow ratio how
do you think about what i'll call more
quantifiable metrics and analysis with
things like regulation or things that
seem to be more external to the asset
itself do you worry about that stuff do
you think about it do you incorporate it
in any way into your analysis
yes i certainly think about it and and
follow it like like a hawk uh because
the big moves in bitcoin were all sort
of triggered by
regulatory changes regulatory clarity
um so i track all the important news and
i put it in the database as well
however i don't use it as an explicit
input variable in my in my models
both the uh
the stock flow model which only has one
input which is stock to flow ratio but
also the on chain models or the floor
models more technical analysis based
models they don't use that kind of
information
but
in fact
those kinds of news events it could be
regulatory news but could also be other
macroeconomic news um
like like el salvador adopting bitcoin
or or china banning bitcoin et cetera
the this this kind of news is very
difficult to predict uh once it happens
and what the impact will be is it priced
in do people expect it or not
so i regard those as trigger events um
that that create
an outlier in the model
or um and that means that there is a
spike uh above the model value or below
the value
uh of the model but those are those
spikes those
those
trigger events are very rare and are
very like black swan events so they they
cause some some variation in models a
model error
but they don't um disturb the general
trend in uh
in the models that's what i would
yeah that's how i look at it and how do
you think about your investing
philosophy do you try to trade around
the asset based on uh all the data you
look at are you just dollar cost
averaging buy and hold like talk to us a
little bit about the philosophy that you
use given that you do have at least a um
an understanding of what some of the
data says does that change what you do
at all
yeah
um
but i i'm more an investor than a trader
and certainly not a day trader so uh
i i bought i was lucky to buy bitcoin
in uh
2015 and 2016 when the price was uh 400
500 uh kindish uh so so
uh those are my my bitcoin investments
and and um
i i've told in other uh interviews as
well that i i sold
uh half of that stash in uh uh well
shortly after the peak in into uh in
december 2017
um
based on uh
stock to flow kind of models so
uh and and i reinvested that half that i
sell
just before i published the article
about stock to flow because i knew
we were at a very low
uh level compared to the stock to flow
model at that time so so in that way i i
sort of trade or sort of try to time the
uh
the peaks and and the bottoms but that's
that's on a monthly or even yearly basis
and i certainly do not trade
uh on an hourly basis that that being
said i am very intrigued as you know by
on chain analysis
i do a lot of
chain analysis and i have a
great team of quants around me um that
can do all sorts of programming uh the
blockchain
data uh
and and and getting signals from there
and that's very very interesting and and
sometimes you can you can actually uh
find patterns that that are tradable on
a daily or or weekly or monthly basis so
on a shorter interval than i'm i'm used
to invest
and and we are
um
yeah
making use of those patterns uh with
algorithmic trading uh software so we
write write our own trading software
that automatically scans for those
anomalies and and uh
yeah make make use of that and that was
one of my skills also uh in my
institutional career that uh yeah the
algorithmic trading part is is very very
interesting in the bitcoin space tell us
more about the institutional interests
whatever you can share whether it's uh
organizations that you work at or have
worked at or uh just kind of
conversations with uh former colleagues
peers people you know in the industry
what's the general sense from the
institutions in terms of bitcoin uh what
they're allocating how they're thinking
about those allocations
yeah so i'm amsterdam based i talk a lot
with
european investors some some u.s
investors but it's it's mainly a
european uh perspective that i have
well certainly the companies that i
worked were not very interested in
in bitcoin yet
because mainly because of uh regulation
and and well misinformation uh
if you will because they most of them
thought it was for criminals it was for
um
and governments would ban it and all
that and and
and of course for an institutional party
like a bank or an insurance company
they have capital regimes uh with their
uh central bank so they'll have to put
capital aside uh for every investment
they make if the investment is more more
risky like bitcoin they have to
um
they have to park more uh capital for
that investment and for bitcoin it's
only is it's almost one to one so if
they if they were
a billion dollars in bitcoin they would
they would have to park at one billion
dollars in in equity as well
and and that is of course not more
doable it's more doable for um for hedge
funds so what i see is it it's not the
big institutions pension funds insurance
companies and banks that are investing
on their own balance sheet or are
interested in bitcoin but it is the
hedge funds the
family offices very much so and
commodity investors especially the gold
and
commodity investors are of course very
much into the same
philosophy that bitcoins have with
sound money
um
and yeah so family offices commodity
investors and
hedge funds those those are the
the ones i see active and the other ones
are
will be late as usual
and when you wake up in the morning like
what do you check first what's the data
sources that you find most valuable
or in terms of just understanding what's
happening in the market whether it's the
short-term or long-term period
um well to be honest the price is one of
the first things the bitcoin price is
one of the first things i check because
that's the most
yeah accurate and and timely information
if if it's the same as
as when i went to bed then nothing
happened if it's if
if it has a big delta then something
happened and then i go on twitter which
i find is my the most direct and and um
and accurate information source there is
because
yeah well one thing i learned is to
to not read mainstream media or watch
mainstream television or even
things
media sources like like cnn and
bloomberg or the wall street journal
that are considered the creme de la
creme in institutional investing
i have to i've learned that with these
new uh investments like like bitcoin you
better
um ditch those uh standard
sources and and go to twitter and the
experts in the field because that's the
yeah
the most direct way of getting
information
yeah and when you think about portfolio
construction uh for yourself or for the
institutions maybe both um is this still
something that is like a very small
allocation or is it something that uh is
being used to like denominate the whole
portfolio or how do you just think about
the portfolio construction and any sort
of concentration uh targets
uh yeah that's a tricky question because
um i think for institutions of course
that's very important to uh to keep the
risk profile sort of constant and within
their mandate so they'll uh they'll have
to sell bitcoin as soon as it rises to
keep to keep the concentration uh low
and within mandate uh boundaries
but with uh
hedge funds or family offices or uh or
for my own investments i don't have
those mandates or boundaries so i can
what i see in practice that what starts
as a small investment a a couple percent
investment in in in bitcoin soon uh
grows to a uh
a double-digit
position in in uh in bitcoin
and uh well after a few years four or
five years it it sort of dominates your
portfolio that sure
is true with my my own investments as
well for sure and then before i let my
brothers ask a couple of questions
what do you think is uh the likely price
for bitcoin by the end of the year and
do you think that the bull market ends
at the end of the year or does it carry
us into the beginning of 2022
yeah that's the most
asked question
uh i
i would be very very surprised if
bitcoin price would be below 100 000
at the end of the year that would
well sort of invalidate my view my
models and uh
that would that would certainly surprise
me i
i do think uh
we will
see
a price that is uh at least 135
000 uh dollars by christmas because uh
that's what my floor model says and uh
basically i'm using three kind of models
that that all say the same thing so
stock to flow which has a hundred
thousand on average for the entire cycle
and we're
mind you we're one and a half years into
that cycle and with below 100 000 prices
so we'll have to to spend the next two
and a half years
markedly above 100 000 to make that that
average
and the second model i use is the
unchain stuff um
that that unchanged stuff is really good
at
identifying bottoms and peaks so
uh we're now talking peaks of course
so i know quite
uh
well certain
not not guaranteed but but i i will have
high high confidence in that the on
chain indicators will signal a top and
if you if we look at the unchanged
signals right now
i would say that top is at least a
couple of months say six months uh
from here so so that would be nfq1 maybe
maybe later
um and then the third kind of models
that i use of course that floor model
135 uh a thousand that's that's not
based on stock to flow it's it's it's
based on other it's a proprietary thing
but it's based on based on other stuff
technical and on chain
um
so
yeah
and by the way that's very good at like
the like the name says on at
indicating bottoms so
i guess we will
be above a hundred thousand above 135
000 at the end of the year and then
we'll continue to grow
maybe towards the stockton floyd x model
targets 288
or even above i would not be surprised
even to see
in q1 or q2 next year
prices of uh
300 400 500 000 uh dollars but i do
think
um and and i noticed you were talking
before in this show that i'm a full bull
that i'm foolbull i am right now
but i'm quite sure that there will be a
time
when i switch from bull to uh to bear
like i did in at the end of 2017
and i'm
yeah to be honest i'm a bit bit of
struggling with that because i i don't
i i i don't want to disclose it because
i want to at least disclose it
responsibly and not be
responsible for triggering the bear
market so uh people have ideas for that
i
um
i i think they're very welcome
and so when you think about that 288 uh
thousand dollar price i think a lot of
people have heard you say that before uh
but when you say that it could go higher
300 400 500 000
is that just pure uh kind of fomo and a
blow off top uh that drives that or is
there something else that you're looking
at that shows that hey maybe we do go
past that 288
that the stock to flow model has there
no no that that will indeed be a fomo
and and that will be very uh clearly
marked in the unchain
analysis which is looking for certain
kinds of transactions that i uh
which i called them before but those are
fomo transactions so so if if if i
if the if the algos um
uh see the the fomo kind of transactions
coming in then the end is near
and yeah so so i would envision like for
example going to 500k
somewhere q2 or something
and then crash back
[Music]
well maybe eighty percent again to to
have 100k
uh have a bit of a bear market and then
continue
another cycle
starting uh
with the halfing in 2024.
going from uh 55 57 000 today to 500k
and q2 back down to 100k and then
continuing into the next halving while
it sounds crazy to uh to a lot of people
uh would be pretty consistent with uh
what we've seen in the past in terms of
volatility uh both up and down so it's
uh so it's interesting to hear you say
that uh joe what questions do you have
yeah plan b thanks for doing this i know
uh i'm a big fan of yours and your
models and your analysis so i know a lot
of others are also my question would be
around uh kind of the correction that
you just spoke of right which is
we're at 57 58 000 now almost uh you're
saying that it's going to average at
least 100 000 over this cycle which is
2020 to 2024 so we obviously have to go
much higher whether it's three hundred
thousand four hundred thousand five
hundred thousand uh we'll see but
traditionally there's also been an
eighty percent correction so is that
something that you think will in in fact
happen again uh and kind of how are you
thinking about that in the long term
yeah i do think that's exactly what will
happen again i can be wrong but right
that's that's let me be very clear i can
be wrong but i do think that four year
cycle that is sort of uh triggered by
the halving
is a
very real thing it has to do with the
scarcity of bitcoin that's the with the
shortage that we're seeing right now
um you know bitcoins are traded on
exchanges and and the exchanges have
some some inventory of bitcoin and then
and you can buy it you can sell it but
it's basically not on chain transactions
it's it's bitcoins that are on the
exchange and you buy them from other
sellers or you sell them to other buyers
but if you look on chain so the
bitcoins that are in cold storage that
large investors have you can
very clearly see these these waves of
shortage and we're in in one right now
uh that that will
at least last another couple of months
before it's uh it's really
well out of salaries if you will but
yeah from from there
um
and and whatever news will trigger it i
don't know i i do think there will be a
crash
um
and it could be as large as the crashes
we've seen in the past we have had three
crashes of 80
and i see no reason why we couldn't have
another one
which of course is always short-lived
and an excellent opportunity to buy more
bitcoin but it could be quite scary for
for newcomers which is
uh
well
precisely what of course those those
cycles do they shake out people that are
leveraged that are uh investing with too
much money that are not certain of their
investment strategy that are
well
does it does you need those those
really committed hotliners if you will
and uh they'll rise again
john what do you think yeah plan b nice
to uh virtually meet you congrats on all
the success so far i know you reached 1
million twitter followers in just about
three years so that's that's pretty
impressive um i want to talk about your
stock to flow model real quick so you
have it projected at hitting about a
million dollars a coin by 2025 do you
believe this do you still believe it and
then if so how do we get there
yes so i i really do uh think that we
have at least one more cycle to go in
the stock to flow prediction uh so yeah
that would bring bitcoin um
in the one one million to five million
dollar range
uh and i do i really do believe that
that we're getting there and so that
would be the path that we're seeing
right now we're we're going from from uh
57 or right now to 63 98 in november
and 35 for example or something above
that right
um in in december and then
then fomo starts to kick in we go to 200
304 and whatever and then crash and from
there we wait till the next halving and
the next half thing will be another
another important fundamental
and even maybe structural event for for
bitcoin because miner i think that's
that's what people misunderstand that
that
that it's all about the um
the supply
and and
the doubling of the the stock to flow
ratio which which is an important part
but the other part is
that miners will have to survive that
event because their their income their
their source of income and their
[Music]
revenue stream will will half and and
they'll have to
switch to uh to new equipment find
better ways
to fund themselves and be much more
efficient in their business and if the
if the miners and the whole business
survives another halving that's a major
accomplishment and and that will trigger
the next the next uh rise from
say a hundred thousand after the next
crash to
uh well 10x
20 30 x
that amount which is yeah in in the
millions indeed
it's pretty crazy when you start to look
at this uh when most people would hear
let's say 2025 a million to five million
that feels like it's a very uh wide
aperture in terms of outcomes help
people understand why it's so hard to
pinpoint you know a million to two
million let alone one to five million
right i don't think people quite
get um kind of this idea of even into q1
q2 of next year if your kind of thesis
plays out
you said hey 288's in the model but 300
400 500 that's a pretty big uh variation
as well so help people understand like
what drives uh that variability there
yeah i think that's an important
question and it's it's uh it's funny to
see that how
naturally and logical that that path of
bitcoin is to me and how amazing it can
be for for newcomers and and and
traditional investors indeed
uh and it's it's the trick is to to look
at it exponentially uh so in logarithmic
scale if you will um because the it's
not about the price level it's about the
growth level the the percentage growth
that is that is constant or or high at
least
and maybe to to uh explain that it
um
if you if you look at my my followers um
which is one million now which was which
was unthinkable even a year ago i let
alone two years ago so three years ago i
started with um i crossed a thousand uh
followers boundary
um
and a a year later i crossed the ten
thousand
and then a year later so the second year
i crossed a hundred thousand and now in
the third year i crossed a million
and
and and if you if you look at that that
path it's it's 10x every year or 20
every month and
so it's amazing growth and and people
start to see it when you're when you're
big but in fact it's it's it's a
constant growth of 20
per month and and yeah that was 200 000
new followers last month but it will
probably be 220
000 new followers next month and and
it's so that 20 is constant and the same
is with the bitcoin price bitcoin goes
uh yeah let's say at
10x every every two years uh so so 100x
every four year period and uh
that is amazing uh if you if yeah to
hear that but if you actually
experience that or look at the data but
that's different that's but if you
experience and as i did of course buying
it for 500
and then going to four or five thousand
and now we're at at forty fifty thousand
that's a hundred x and that and there
are people that have thousand x their
investment or ten thousand digs and that
that that constant uh growth
i guess is very uh specific to bitcoin
and uh triggered by the halving
periods the scarcity that's intrinsic in
bitcoin and that makes it such a perfect
store of value and and more of more
people more and more people will
recognize this this unique property
what's the thing that uh when you look
forward you're most excited too is there
a price milestone is there a number of
entities on chain is there some sort of
uh kind of external milestone what's the
thing that you're like man when this
happens that's gonna be pretty cool i'm
really looking forward to it
well uh on the short term i would be
very uh would be very nice if we hit
that 63 000 mark end of this month
because i guess that that's what really
did it last time nailing the 47 and 43
000 last two months so 63 would be nice
of course the 100k the 100k is sort of
the make or break
from for the stock to flow models i i
really hope we hit that and and i'm
quite certain
uh or not uncertain i should say that
we're going to hit that
and after that um
i think the most amazing thing
for most people and also for myself will
be
that om chain model turning red the fomo
transactions that will be detectable
and me uh
as the full bull
um
turning uh turning bare and um
as i said i'm struggling with that how
to communicate it maybe that's the best
time to go dark
but um
yeah i think there will be a time where
we switch
from bull to bear and that of course is
is
a uh
a great
a great thing uh of a model that it's
it's not always uh
but that and you're not always a moon
boy but that you that you can
predict the downsides as well so yeah
i'm not looking forward to it
on the one hand but i i i feel it's
gonna happen someday
uh later next year but yeah i'm very
much sort of looking forward to that
moment do you have any thoughts on a
bitcoin etf and how that could either
support accelerate or be detrimental
to uh stock the flow model
yes stock to flow
etf will make bitcoin available for the
masses for for uh pop mom and
investors and yeah it will be a huge
thing for the market um
although we of course
think well you can you can buy bitcoin
right now why why should you pay the uh
the fees that are associated with these
funds but it makes it easy for for the
crowds the hurt will be coming then and
that will be a big big thing so
yeah i think it's coming maybe this
month um maybe next month but it will it
will be there of course the uh
gary gansler from the sec has already
sort of notched
that that it is possible to start a
futures bitcoin futures etf right now
which um
which i think
has already been
receiving applications for that at the
moment so so yeah
i would be very surprised that would not
be introduced this year
and what i also found very interesting
was that one of the applications and one
of the interviews with with one of the
uh future etfs bitcoin etfs was that
they mentioned stock flow model as one
of the models that they're tracking uh
for future value and uh yeah
i think that's once you've seen that
once you've
once you understand the exponential
growth and the four year cycles
yeah i think it's it's an asset you
cannot you cannot deny
how about the macro environment things
like interest rates or quantitative
easing both in the united states and
abroad how do you think about that
affecting this is it something where uh
bitcoin just remains not correlated and
you know it's worth paying attention to
but it doesn't ultimately have an effect
on price or do you think that we've seen
more correlation and therefore if
there's some sort of tapering or
kind of slow down in some of those
activities that it could be negative for
bitcoin
yeah i think it's very important i think
it's the
one of the reasons that satoshi of
course made bitcoin it was against the
basement against money printing which
was uh very much uh
present in 2008 when he wrote the
write paper white paper in the software
because that was at the peak of the
financial crisis the global financial
crisis at the time and the white paper
was uh the bitcoin white paper was
published uh 45 days after the lehman
default
so yeah it's very very important it's
also one of the reasons that i started
looking from an institutional investor
point of view
um towards alternative investments
because because i saw that especially in
europe of course we have negative
interest rates and that yeah that turns
your world upside down that you yeah
school or university doesn't teach you
that so
how do you survive a negative interest
rate uh environment and what does that
tell you negative interest rates so
well everybody's looking for yield and
and rates that are not negative
i started looking at alternatives and
came to uh came to bit going through
that so i'm very grateful to the central
bankers for introducing quantitative
easing and negative interest rates
because otherwise i would never have
found
bitcoin
um so yeah i think
what we also saw is that all the price
uh movement a lot of price movement uh
in other markets like like the stock
market like the s p 500 were
um
related or correlated with with uh
uh quantitative easing and possible
tapering and and uh
yeah uh the money printing if you will
so if if money is printed that money has
to go somewhere and first it will be to
bonds uh government bonds but the
receivers of those bonds usually banks
or governments
uh will spend that money again and and
so it will end up in the hands of the
well the second layer that receives that
that money and uh
and some of those those companies and
and people will buy equities real estate
and bitcoin and that's why we see all
these markets go up because there's just
too much money and in a way it's just
yeah too much money chasing few goods so
all the prices of those assets go up
asset inflation is very real these days
as
all the invest
real estate investors will notice as
well and equity investors as well so
um will the markets decouple well it
seems like it today
or this week because bitcoin goes up and
all the other markets are not following
uh even the altcoin markets are not uh
not following bitcoin this time so
i guess in the end um
bitcoin is the ultimate store of value
[Music]
consistent with my stock to flow model
it it is not as scarce as
as gold or about as scarce as gold today
but not as scarce as real estate today
so real estate is one of these big
money
uh sort of values um today but in the
end bitcoin will have this the same
scarcity the same stock to flow ratio as
real estate and it will be portable and
communicatable by by a phone line by
internet connection so it will be better
than gold and real estate together and
once people see that the the lids are
off and we go
much higher in price than we're at today
how do you think about those other
assets right either uh for your own uh
portfolio or for those investors is this
something where let's take real estate
investors uh they begin to see that
asset appreciation they see their rents
going up they're continuing to make more
and more money and is it a thing where
like that capital eventually will flow
into bitcoin as well uh because they
understand store value they understand
scarcity they understand like a hard
asset uh compared to that fiat
devaluation or do you think that people
who have been investing in the analog
markets
like a real estate investor they just
have a hard time understanding buying a
virtual uh item or something that is
this like global digital decentralized
store value
yeah both points are true i think uh so
money will start to flow uh from real
estate and gold and and and other
investments towards bitcoin the new
investment and and yes it is a
generational thing as well because uh
the older guys that are not used to uh
computers
they will have difficulty with
understanding um virtual assets you see
it with peter schiff i i i know a lot of
people that are like peter schiff the
old uh
gold bugs if you will and i was a gold
buck at the time but
um people that that
that cannot program that that that that
are late in the computer
thing
they will not appreciate their virtual
aspect of bitcoin and and they cannot
understand uh digital scarcity so
they'll they'll clamp
to to real estate and and and their
their
trusted asset like like gold
but but in the end um yeah
the younger people will uh
will um will turn up and and and have
all the money and and those are people
that have been
teach computers and they have been on
their iphone all day and there's nothing
scary about digital assets at all and
they'll that that's what you see in
family offices so the younger generation
is is pitching about bitcoin and the
older generation is against it and and
well they try one percent that becomes
ten percent of the allocation and and i
think that's that's how it will go and
even with my own uh portfolio i was i
was like uh
well like most people diversified 25
real estate 25
equity 25 gold 25
new stuff alternative stuff say bitcoin
but that bitcoin percentage grew and
grew and you learn and you think like
well yeah i'm not going to rebalance i'm
not going to sell my best best running
asset to to put it into gold or
something so
or buy an extra house why should i so
yeah i think i think it will be a very
natural thing with uh generations uh the
new generations coming into power
and from a gold perspective everyone is
very interested in the kind of the
flipping right this idea that uh
bitcoin's market cap will eventually
grow to be bigger than gold's most
people will point to gold's market cap
at 10 11 trillion dollars uh and bitcoin
being right over 1 trillion so kind of
10 11 x one of the things i've been very
interested in is
i actually think that gold's market cap
is going to collapse uh over time and so
the flipping doesn't happen around 10 11
trillion it happens somewhere lower and
maybe that's nine trillion maybe that's
you know six seven eight trillion i
don't really know where but just the
idea that uh in order for bitcoin to
continue to grow we are likely to see a
collapse in gold's market cap is that
your view as well or do you disagree
yeah i'm not a gold expert but i know a
lot of cold experts and i talk a lot
with a lot with them
so i might be wrong on the gold thing
but i agree
that i think gold will eventually
go down in
in market cap
and lose that money to
to other investments like real estate or
bitcoin
um
what i think will i
what i think the big bet that that gold
investors take is is that it will once
again
be used by central bankers as the
backing of a new world currency and that
could very well be right the the central
banks are talking of the next bretton
woods moment they are talking about a
global currency could very well be the
ims
special drawing rice the scr
and and yes maybe that would be
a uh
currency a a uh
sdr backed by gold but that's the entire
bat the entire play they're doing so if
that happens of course gold will pump
will go up in market cap but i don't
think they're going to do that and i
and in fact bitcoin is
much cleaner in in um
with respect that it does not have to be
uh backed by anything it's backed by
well
um
the energy
and the mining in in bitcoin but not by
another asset and not an account or
an accountability problem that's as
associated with that
and that we see in gold for example
because yeah how much gold is there in
fort knox how much gold to the chinese
central bank how much do they really
have we don't know and and with bitcoin
it's very transparent it's it's all on
the blockchain
and yeah in the end
uh
from a
thermo
dynamic point of view from an energy
point of view
that is so much more efficient for the
human race and i guess
yeah we will tilt towards bitcoin
because it's just better money i i tend
to agree do you think that uh eventually
the nation states adopt bitcoin uh and
it kind of grows to be a global reserve
currency do you think it's a currency of
the internet how do you see kind of the
ultimate destination uh for this asset
if you think it's better money
yeah i think i think uh governments will
adapt bitcoin like like el salvador did
it kind of amazes me that not other
states have and nations have adopted it
because it's the
yeah most most logical thing to do
especially if they're under the uh
pressure and and the
regime of the imf if they're kept on a
leash
with with debt
um which is certainly something that
most countries
will probably hate
but but of course the leaders of those
companies will be
um greatly paid by by imf and and to
keep to keep that status quo but yeah
most countries would be better off by
switching to something other than debt
and especially
euros dollar denominated debt so
especially in south america mid america
africa
there must be countries uh
that that are are going that route
and i
following the
brazilian
trend closely because that government is
some very spectacular stuff
and i'm also following some eastern
european countries like the ukraine and
the countries that belong to
the former russia and are now sort of
more oriented to to europe or but but
not part of the european union so so
they
yeah
they can they can switch to bitcoin i
think some some countries will and i
really hope that that will happen on the
other hand um i do think it's in the end
a
thing that's not decided by by states
especially in the united states um
and europe
it's it's something that's also decided
by banks that um that are already much
larger larger than most states
especially um
states like the netherlands where i live
which is very small and a typical bank
is like like a multiple in size of
that small country so so companies banks
and also people
um
will decide that they park their money
in bitcoin and not in
in their negative interest
rate yielding uh
saving accounts at the bank
and that will that will be a large and
growing force with that same exponential
uh
uh constant exponential that we see in
the bitcoin price or my follower count
or or
some other things that go exponential
very interesting
plan b i could literally talk to you for
hours uh over the years as i've seen uh
your audience grow uh seeing you put out
more and more content i've just been
super impressed um and so uh i think now
i think this is true uh michael saylor
myself and you all have 1 million
followers
my hope is that you beat me to 2 million
because if you beat me to 2 million that
means that you've not only continued uh
but you've likely been right uh which
means that most people uh who are
listening to this would be very very big
fans of you so you know just from
everyone else uh and me just thank you
for all the work that you've done all
the contribution you've made to the
community it's uh it's pretty cool to
see um how somebody who literally i've
never met in person i don't know your
name i have no clue what you look like
uh i'm talking to a pseudo-anonymous
identity on the internet and uh you've
touched so many people been able to
build this large following and it's all
because of the quality of the work it
just stands on that alone um is pretty
incredible so just thank you for doing
all that
well thank you very much and thank you
for that last minute boost around the 1
million as well that that really did it
and i'm going after you guys right i'll
uh have a sailor and you are above me
and i sort of calculated already that um
maybe before the summer at the current
uh
growth rate that could be number one but
who knows well listen i'm here putting
your link uh for people to follow you on
twitter in the chat i may stop doing
that if i know you're coming for it
thanks for everything man of course i
appreciate you coming on i think my
brothers uh every day they say well plan
b said so uh so they're fans as well um
anyone who uh who's listening to this
make sure you go follow them on twitter
and uh we'll talk soon my friend
thanks guys bye